今天是家庭版水光海外秀的跟练
这是家庭版海外秀的境界版
你刚做完只会感觉望
毛孔是很通唱的
但是明天早上睡醒
你就会发现你的皮膚
会变得非常的透亮
非常地有光折
第一步还是软化脚致
松棟油汁
用我们的黑头到处验
我现在是刚喜欢脚的状态
这个最好就是喜欢脚致后座
毛孔是张开的效果会比较好
服在我们练上这种
有指索迷望圣
脚致曾有很靠的区
一开练上脚致曾保的区域
这个喝的脚致又已经用了4年了
非常好用我都是直接买他们家
那个运线状就是1000号圣的
小汉很多的皮膚扣用的都是这个
然后我们再来加一个热棚
我热棚的话
清潔效果可以从70分到90分
它那时候进入发现的比较厉害
我感觉水全部都碰完了
现在开始你们最爱的很节
穿油汁
展示前凰酒精凉
变成才能像
穿的时候不要一次性就把这些面片全部结开了
就是产那个部位
就接那个部位
变要用这个棉片不停的
打拭我们的皮膚
这样才不容易把皮膚插扣皮
这个仪器也是长起来的
然后它的传统是长起来的
从下往上挂
穿完路
今天好像还好没有传统很多
刚才用清水把肯定导致下洗掉
对面再来扶一片藍膜
利用封面膜皮膚水盒的原理
把毛孔里面的就是油脂
让它扶出来
正面还可以用这个面膜
给皮膚做一个震静和书反
它这个面膜的模布
用我的皮膚做的顏色和封
像这种边边讲讲
它都可以给我扶到
我在海外效里面长
是过很多面膜
还是蓝膜
它帮我扶出的油脂
对多
退红的效果也很牛
因为我的鼻子
它是那种油脂
非常多的
所以我会在鼻子对面
再扶一个棉片加一个压
面膜里面还用的精华
棉片加上这个精华
在重演的压住
让黑头都扶起来
我大概扶了十多分钟
现在
第二步传油脂的环节了
直接把抹膜塑下来就行
但是不要丢拿着手里面
边传
便使软这样子的话
唱完基本上就能退红
那亲的时候就把来按的皮膚上
稍微的用一点力
让皮膚有亲味的
熬下去的感觉
然后亲鼻子的时候
就是从上往下慢慢的
滑下去就行了
不要这样
真正来回过按
一个方向
往下面顺就行了
你看我就是
一边亲
一边用那个抹布
它是皮膚
所以亲玩了之后
马上就退红了
好了
我现在亲玩了
你们展示一下我的战力品
就是这些东西
它一直都在抹抹抹装里面
把我们的抹抹抹都穿大了
让我们长闭口的员胸
也是它
那现在我再用清水
把我脸上的精华也洗掉
把脸上水分都它干净
现在我们干手干脸的
来扶一个酸洞膜
这是我们清减的
最后一步
刚才我们已经把抹抹抹
表面和抹抹里面的
有值得清楚来了
酸洞膜
可以再一次地去树洞膜
这个时候用酸
它才能够真正的
进入到我们的抹抹抹里面
去帮我们洗刷抹抹抹抹
我用的就是多酸
它就是复核酸
里面有可以抹光的抹酸
有可以淡化红黑都硬的整二酸
还有树头抹抹抹
信你皮膚的血氧酸
就有没有用皮来说
准复很全面
不复的时候
这两块是比较薄的
所以我不会付到这两边
这个酸
我大概付个一两分钟
我就会就洗掉
洗完了
现在皮膚好光滑
现在开始我们后续的抹抹
到了我们家庭板水光
还要秀的精水了
主要就是靠这个滋水光
但今天我还会在前面加一个教员泡
就是我最近的新冠
教员泡就很适合做完这种
生存清潔之后用
现在毛孔都是干干淨淨的
教员才能被我们皮膚都吃进去
教员泡吸收完
现在我们再用一只滋水光
它就有相当于图抹涉的水光了
我一般用半只
但是如果你的脸能把一只都吃进去
那么用一只效果会更好
用了当下你不会觉得
那是明天早上起来
就会觉得整个脸真的就跟
比我玩水光一模一样
还女的那种非常透亮的水光感
它比我之前在外面
比我过的水光效果要更好
而且它没有恢复起
明天就可以上装
让它吸收进去
现在都吸收完了
看一下皮膚的状态
最后来一个修复面装收尾
面双也要选这种有修复力的
而且是要这种
清爽部门斗的修复面装
不要刚清完
然后又搞一个很认很认的那种
修复面装湖在脸上
后来修复了现在来个冰水
用热张的桌子远离
再一起的收收一下毛孔
然后现在这个家庭版水光
还被修中几乎你就做完了
你刚做完你只会感觉挖
毛孔是很通唱的
然后皮膚是摸起来很光滑
很柔嫩的
但是明天早上睡醒
你就会发现你的皮膚
会变得非常的透亮
非常的有光折
而且摸起来整个脸真的有软软的
谈谈的嫩嫩的
而且这种状态
就坚持每周做一次
这个家庭版水光还被修
皮膚状态真的都是会
越来越好